I've got you uh right if you at all bear
with us for a moment as I start our live
stream for our LinkedIn audience you can
see we have Seema sahai here with us
yeah
take me just a moment to get this
started
and
okay very good Welcome to our LinkedIn
live audience our YouTube live audience
and of course everyone here on WebEx
with us
and I'm here with
SEMA sahai who will be speaking with us
about
creating a career mindset a mindset for
Career Success in 2023
um
before I turn it over to SEMA we have a
couple things to get us started
okay
Tim are you seeing my screen
yes I am
and we want to start by letting you know
that if you're on the WebEx application
you can put your questions in the Q a
panel
uh we'll take those toward the end of
the session in the Q and A's portion and
if you're on one of the streaming
services please put your questions into
the chat or comment box
and we'll start off also before we get
uh
famous questions here
second
okay
okay
foreign
the webinar
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
oh my God
oh my buddy
what happened something hello are you
are you able to hear me again
yes uh Stuart I can hear you very
clearly yeah
I apologize uh WebEx Pros on my desktop
okay
I think
uh give me just a moment
um SEMA I will try to give you the
sharing privilege so that you can begin
the information we'll deal with the
polls later
uh
uh hold on a second here
give me just a couple moments while I
rejoined the webinar
and uh if you haven't already SEMA
please do introduce yourself
okay so can I share
uh not quite yet okay okay I've been
having a system difficulty and then when
you tell me I'll share the screen yeah
all right
this is the presentation that you're
running
okay now now it's okay
all right
I apologize for the technical
difficulties yeah that happens so many
times doesn't it
if you want I can start
but I don't need to I would need I'm
trying to give you the sharing purpose
folder yes yes yes
you should have the sharing for your
privilege now
yes I do
I do I do let me share the screen
and
so can you see my screens to it
yes yes okay
foreign
good evening everyone I hope I am
Audible
and there seems to be some technical
glitch but now I think that's fine
so good evening Stuart and I hope you
can hear me
yes everything's working from your end
okay great
so uh
here's a short introduction
to me and uh it's a pleasure to be here
today this evening on the platform of
Simply learn I am Seema sahai I'm a
career enhancement coach author
communication specialist personal
branding strategist keynote speaker
International English trainer and voice
coach and I have over two 24 years of
experience in education training
academics and coaching and basically as
a career enhancement coach I enable
aspirants and professionals to secure
and enhance and grow their jobs with
certain skills and these are functional
career skills and I am an
internationally certified TTT and soft
skills trainer and accomplished
corporate Communications trainer as I
just said
I am also the author of two books uh one
the first one is
secure scale Skyrocket nine career
skills for professional success and I
have been editor of an International
magazine called Indian Dairy men and I
have influenced and impacted over 20 000
people globally and my mission is to
help one million people Skyrocket their
careers so this in short
is a brief introduction about me and
without wasting much time
um
the topic for today is creating a
mindset for Career Success in 2023
now uh it's almost the end of the year
uh it is 21st December almost the end of
the year and hopefully the end of uh
almost two or three years of pandemic
that had brought the world upside down
for us
and uh I hope that all of us are doing
well and I'm sure all of us are doing
well and uh you know in an upbeat mood
for the ensuing year and uh yes it has
not been a Rosy you know it has not been
Rosy and it is uh not going to be Rosy
uh ahead you know as well uh you know
there's a talk of uh looming recession
that have been massive massive layoffs
and there is a general sense of
instability
so
nevertheless as we ponder over the ear
gone by the positives far outweigh the
negatives and to ensure that it remains
like that we have to put in our best
efforts no matter what the situation
so uh uh you know uh you know because of
the emerging career Trends which we'll
be talking about the emerging career
Trends requires us to have a new skill
sets or to have enhanced skill sets but
more important than that is the need to
inculcate the right mindset for
achieving professional growth and
fulfillment so let me Begin by showing
you a picture
foreign
who this person is on the screen if you
can write it in the chat uh that'll be
nice you can mention it in the chat who
is this person in the picture
um
maybe if I can show you another picture
it'll be even more clear
so yes who hasn't heard of KFC Kentucky
Fried Chicken and so many of us have
savored it but a lot of us don't know
the story behind its founder and that is
Colonel uh Holland standards so uh this
is the first picture and that is the
first picture the person is Colonel
Holland Sanders so he was a school
dropout and later on he of course opened
a restaurant which he wanted to
franchise
uh but his recipe of chicken got
rejected
1009 times
1009 times before it was finally
accepted so the lesson over here is that
um and this this recipe of course at
later later on you know I went on to
become the secret recipe of Kentucky
Fried Chicken and the lesson over here
is do not be disheartened by failure and
resilience should be the name of the
game so uh this is uh what as we go into
23 this is what the Mantra should be
that do not let failure put you back
pull you back if you have the courage of
your convictions if you believe in what
you uh if you believe in what you want
to do then you will overcome all kinds
of failure so that is the message over
here and now another picture and no
prizes for guessing this one yes this is
the iconic author JK Rowling of Harry
Potter Fame and uh
now we've all heard how her manuscript
Harry Potter manuscript got rejected 12
times before it was finally accepted and
accepted by a publisher Bloomsbury so
again this displays the Never Say Die
Spirit of the author or the resilient
Spirit of the author again and then we
move on to one of my most favorite books
and uh it is just 90 pages long it is a
uh it has a wealth of meaning and
learning and it has four characters two
little mice and two little people so two
mice and two little people and they live
in a maze and they feed on cheese any
guess what I'm talking about which book
am I talking about
no guesses okay so the book is who a lot
of yes Joseph Wilson who Moved My Cheese
a lot of you must have read it and uh so
these two uh these four characters they
feed on cheese and when the cheese gets
over the two little mice that is uh
Scurry Sniff and Scurry they look for
new cheese while the two little people
they feel betrayed and they feel
depressed and they feel deprived and
they feel that life hasn't treated them
fairly and they stay in a rut all the
time so again the lesson here is change
is the only constant so if we want
growth we need to move out of our
comfort zones and look for new cheese so
to say and so even when the odds are
against us and uh with a little shift in
our perspective with a little shift in
our mindset we can achieve what we have
set out to do with the correct attitude
in 2023
so as I said the change of mindset is
required you can call it the growth
mindset abundance mindset of abundance
positive mindset job Seekers mindset a
mindset of Excellence or Career Success
mindset and that is why since your mind
is such a powerful weapon today as I
begin my session I will be focusing on
three important things and these are how
to create the correct mindset for
personal and professional growth how to
have the correct mindset to decide which
emerging career Trends are right for you
and how to upskill and reskill for
Career Success so in 2023 when you are
working towards your success goals
success would definitely depend on your
qualifications your experience your
education the right opportunities that
you get your skill skills your personal
brand but to more important than that
more than anything else it will depend
on whether you are success oriented or
whether you have a success oriented
mindset or a growth mindset so because
that you know the technology and is
advancing very fast very rapidly and the
nature of work post pandemic has been
changing very very rapidly so you need
to keep on learning new skills to remain
competitive
now according to a McKenzie report about
375 million workers globally will need
to change roles or learn new skills by
2030. so it is obvious that people are
not going to be hired for what they know
but they are going to be hired for for
the ability to learn uh what they do not
know so that concept of continuous
learning that concept of evolving
continuously is very important and it'll
play a very crucial role in your Career
Success so according to again a survey
by Evolution published in LinkedIn 96 of
people see a positive impact of
continuous learning on work performance
and 78 people see it as a factor in
promotions and career growth and an
enhanced paycheck and
here the importance of the right or the
correct mindset cannot be negated so
when we talk of mindsets please note
that there are two kinds of mindset
first is the fixed mindset and the
second is the growth mindset so Carol
dweck in her book mindset the new
psychology of success says that the way
we think about our abilities our
capabilities our talents defines and
determines whether we are successful or
not the so if you believe your
intelligence your creativity your
talents your character are static they
cannot be changed and they cannot be
improved upon and you accept it
unquestioningly then you have a fixed
mindset so most probably you will
stagnate in your careers and you will
not simply because you will not Aspire
for more challenging
opportunities uh because you think
you're not capable of them on the other
hand if you feel if you believe that
your qualities your skills your thought
patterns your uh habits your
um mindset I sorry yours your psychology
of thinking all these things if you
think they can be improved with practice
they can be improved with effort
conscious effort so then you will
continue to evolve and that is the
Hallmark of a growth mindset so this is
what uh is very important to keep in
mind so when we talk of a growth mindset
or a success mindset we need to see it
as an all-inclusive phenomena
you cannot have a success mindset only
visible your career you know because
your professional life is going to
flourish only if you nourish your
personal life so uh there is a very
famous motivational speaker called John
uh called uh Jim Ron and he has said
that his uh his uh he his Focus was only
on his job initially he wanted to make a
lot of money he wanted to have success
in his career but only when he started
focusing on his own personal development
did he see great uh great enhancement in
his career so it is very important to
invest in yourself and in order to uh in
order to see returns in your career you
must first focus on your own personal
growth so
the number one belief that leads to the
number one habit that leads to the
number one
um number one mindset is uh as far as
the personal development is concerned as
far as self-growth is concerned is to
follow the Rope principle now what is
the Rope principle r o p e it is the
rate of personal Evolution the rate of
personal Evolution so your question life
should be to grow in all walks of life
so mistakenly we focus only on our
careers our careers can grow only if we
grow ourselves so to have more you have
to Simply become more so in the
beginning of your career go for
intensive and deep learning more
knowledge more skills will give you the
first mover advantage and
in fact start when you are still
studying as a student explore more
opportunities explore those activities
which you are passionate about which you
are interested in go for volunteering
activities go for internships and try to
solve problems go for networking and try
to see whether you can solve problems
for people because not only will it be a
learning experience you will also
realize you will also be aware what are
the things what are the domains you are
interested in and you want to improve
your skills in that domain it will also
teach you on the other hand what you are
not very passionate about and what you
do not want to do in the future so that
is why the Rope principle is very very
important and an actionable strategy for
all young professionals is don't look
for Less Problems look for more skills
not less problems but more skills should
be your motto and an actionable strategy
for all professionals is work hard and
work smart on your career but work hard
and work more smart on your personal
development so work on your yourself
more than and then only will you see the
returns in your career so work on
acquiring the relevant skills and make
yourself more valuable in the
marketplace
if you do that very soon you will find
that the Golden Rule has become your
income is directly proportionate to your
attitude to your skills to your
abilities to your talents to your
thought patterns to your personality and
not to the economy so this is one thing
going forward we have to keep in mind do
not just blame the economy or this or
the situation that is around but to work
on yourself that is very important so
when you think of crafting an effective
and satisfying career there are three
things to be kept in mind first does it
provide me professional fulfillment now
this means does it meet my expectations
and my skill sets the second is does it
give me the remuneration that I deserve
now this will happen only if you work if
your work is creating some
some value to others in your
organization or to your company as a
whole so ask yourself what is it I can
do what is it am I going beyond my job
description am I doing something else
something more than what the job
requires and the third thing also is
very important does it provide a culture
where my personal values and vision are
aligned with those of the organization
now this is so because your personal
values is and your personal development
is as I said intrinsically linked to
your professional development your
professional growth and so what are some
of the ways in which you can invest in
yourself in your self-evolution so this
is the question that we need to answer
and that is why let us look at uh six
key components of developing personal
excellence in 2012 2023
what is the first one
be a continuous learner so people with a
success mindset have a childlike
curiosity of learning new things of
exploring new things and the best way to
feed this intellectual curiosity is by
reading and reading voraciously so
inspirational books motivational books
uh by uh biographies and
self-improvement books fiction
non-fiction whatever drives you all of
them are going to have a tremendous
impact on the way you think on the way
you behave and the way you communicate
so isn't that wonderful for our own
personal brand and personal brand is
very very important in this uh in in
this quest for a satisfying career so
that is the first one
the next is failure is good accepted it
might sound contradictory but all
successful people know that this is true
you have to view failure as a positive
entity now because why because your
mistakes will provide learnings to you
uh Steven Spielberg was rejected from uh
film school three times before he was
finally accepted and we have all heard
of Oprah Winfrey she was thought
unsuitable to become a news anchor and
she was dismissed from her job later on
of course she went on to become one of
the most iconic television hosts of all
time so uh as my mentor has also said I
also try to follow this principle my
mentor had said make a mess but let that
mess be a message for others so I uh
have made a lot of messes uh know
because my career trajectories have been
very different and diverse all
throughout and so that is why
you know you cannot really uh say that
failure is not a learning experience the
next one is develop a long-term Vision
now it's very important to set
actionable goals for yourself in all
areas of life be it personal be it uh
professional so in this regard there is
one tip which you can execute and that
is follow the 25 by 25 rule what is the
25 by 25 rule make a list of the top 25
personal and professional goals that are
most important to you out of these take
the five the top five or the most
crucial five uh uh five of the goals and
these are your top five goals focus on
them only the caveat is accomplish those
five goals in the time frame which you
have said do not look at the other 20.
keep away from the other 20. why because
uh there are a lot of times when
um when we are distracted by too many
other things we want to do it all we
want to achieve it all we find so many
things interesting and we find uh so
many things
um attempting and we want to do it now
this kind of an attitude is called the
shiny object syndrome and uh we think
that okay some other person is achieving
so many goals let me also do that this
distracts us from our key areas of focus
and our and our growth is hampered so
this kind of a long-term vision is very
important the next one is challenge
yourself uh you are getting a good
paycheck you have a steady job and
chances are you will get very
comfortable in your job so when you find
yourself doing routine jobs when you
find that there is nothing very
challenging or creative about your job
please understand that you have stopped
growing so again always look for a more
exciting and more diverse opportunities
and experiences so I can again give my
own example I started as an academic and
I was teaching English for several years
before I went on to teach mass
communication then I became an editor of
a magazine later on I became an author
and of course a corporate trainer so all
these have been learning experiences I
have been challenging myself to learn
different kinds of things and have
different kinds of experiences so keep
raising the bar constantly and in in
fact there is a Japanese term called
Kaizen so there is a Japanese term which
means Kaizen which means how can I do
even better so ask yourself how can I go
the extra mile in my organization how
can I provide more value so this so this
kind of challenge these kind of
challenges are very important the next
is always welcome feedback so there is a
popular adage and that says feedback is
the Breakfast of Champions so
at your workplace try to find a mentor
if you are not working try to find a
mentor again so uh it could be at your
workplace it could be your co-workers
and one of your co-workers your manager
your colleague anyone and do not be
scared and do not shun constructive
criticism because people with a growth
mindset people with a learning mindset
they always welcome this kind of
criticism and judgment because it
enables them to improve their own
performance in the areas in which they
are lacking so feedback is always good
and the last but not the least never
fear competition so today jobs are
scarce and roles are limited and talent
is abundant so obviously there will be
competition at the workplace but people
again with a positive mindset are not
scared of it in fact they are inspired
and motivated by the achievements of
their peers of their colleagues of their
seniors and even subordinates of people
from the other department because again
it Spurs them to do their best and to to
sort of challenge themselves to improve
themselves in another in other areas in
which they are not up to the mark so uh
these are the six strategies through
which you can develop personal
excellence and it will always reflect in
your career graph
so now
as we look ahead to 2023 it is important
to reflect on your career path of the
past one year ask yourself a few
questions could you achieve the goals
you had set out for yourself what were
the successes the challenges the
learnings is your career where you want
it to be if not what do you need to do
about it do you need to learn a
different or a new skill set uh or do
you do you need to strengthen the
existing ones uh you had envisioned a
life for yourself in the beginning of
the year and you had set goals is your
work contributing into making that kind
of life so these are some of the
questions you should now ask yourself
because your choice of career and
success will depend on all these factors
after this checklist which will give you
a better view of all aspects is you can
set fresh goals for 23. and
um
I'm gonna put a short survey that you've
asked me to share into the chat for
everyone so
it'll come right up in the chat for you
everyone please
go to that link when you have a chance
thank you just wanted to let you know
that I was doing that
yeah so
so this is I think a short form and you
just need to fill it in and submit it
okay good to go
looks like people have finished you yes
so now now that uh
wrought about a shift in perspective
through our mindsets we have learned
about the Rope principle we have learned
how personal investment and growth is
very important let us look at some of
the most popular jobs and discover what
the emerging career Trends are going to
be so uh these are 12 uh 12 best paying
jobs in 23 these are called the jobs of
the future the jobs for tomorrow let us
briefly Talk of the skill requirements
as well of all these jobs the first one
is data science or data analysis now
this will always be relevant because
these jobs are future proof as far as
core or domain skills for this for acing
this kind of a job go uh you need to
have a basic knowledge of coding you
need to have a you know data analysis
maths and stats uh abilities as far as
your functional career skills or your
power skills or as they are called soft
skills go you must have good
presentation skills the next one is
machine learning and AI artificial
intelligence now uh here
uh now this is a organization so value
this a lot because it is a way to
protect their businesses from future
disruptions now the core skills required
over here would be software designing
and programming Etc and the power skills
or soft skills would be uh good
Communications problem solving abilities
continuous learning and time management
the next is Healthcare and Healthcare
support again this is always in demand
but this group specifically specially
during the pandemic and uh because you
know Health was the most important thing
at that time and Quality Health Care of
course is always in demand so the core
skills over here would be awareness
about the latest medical practices and
the power skills would be your
interpersonal competencies that is is
your ability to communicate with
patients you should have the aptitude to
educate patients and that is why your
Communications will be very important
the fourth is business or marketing
analysis and Analysis and a marketing
analyst is expected to analyze data sets
of market segments or campaigns and come
up with usable insights so the core
skills over here you require both
scientific knowledge and business Acumen
and the soft skills would be again
Communications which is important all
across and critical thinking the next is
project management project management
about 89 organizations have at least one
project management officer the core
skills a project manager would require
they should ensure that all resources
are utilized in the most efficient way
and the power skills would be people
management leadership efficient planning
strategizing time management
communication skills adaptability
because it involves overseas travel and
these are a host of transferable skills
that would come in good stead for a
project manager
the next is human resources again always
in demand it is an essential part of any
organization and this has seen a lot of
transformation during the during the
pandemic and post pandemic as well
because the nature of work has changed
from online to hybrid to uh you know it
has worked from anywhere so it has seen
a lot of changes here are the core
skills required would be to enable the
workforce to adapt and adopt new working
models and the power skills would be
they should have again great
communication skills and interpersonal
skills and the ability for team
orientation so these are some of the
skills for human resources people next
is digital marketing again the scope has
only grown post pandemic because the
nature of work has changed and take
technology has been changing rapidly so
the core skills would be a thorough
understanding of SEO of keywords and of
affiliate marketing and the power skills
would be great Communications uh
all throughout
because you need to create a lot of
content as well so uh some other best
paying jobs well-paying jobs are product
management Cloud architect cyber
security financial management and
management consulting I will quickly run
through all of these so a product
product manager develops products and
services for customers and he has to
pitch ideas uh very very uh uh pitch his
ideas in a very clever manner so the
soft skills that would be required are
critical thinking and analytical skill
and analytic analytical skills and he
should have he or he he or she should
have a problem solving tent of Mind as
far as a cloud architect goes they focus
on the future they plan and design
strategies and systems to meet customer
requirements so the core skills would be
coding in Java python Etc raw and the
soft skills would be networking and
communication because you need to
explain your ideas very well over here
the next is cyber security it is
important because there have been so
many instances of crime and breaches uh
in the uh on the internet so the core
skills would be scripting regulatory
guidelines should be known to the person
privacy laws should be known to the
person and the soft skills would be
collaboration because you need to work
with others maybe you need to work with
other departments like legal the I.T the
pr
Etc then we have financial management
you manage the Investment Portfolio of
your company that is your role as a
financial manager so the core skills are
risk management and a business Acumen
and the soft skills are you need to have
good presentation skills and the last is
management resulting providing
consulting services to organizations to
improve their business so these are just
some of the jobs you can look out for
going forward and you must develop the
transferable skills for all these jobs
specifically and so that you can adapt
to the job and the role you are expected
to perform
now this is because in a recent LinkedIn
data it shows that the skill sets of
jobs have changed by around 25 percent
since 2015 and by 2027 the number is
expected to double and that is why a
skills first mindset is imperative now
as I said there is a very common
misconception that in order to survive
in today's job scenario we need to
develop High technological and
scientific skills yes they are important
they are necessary but equally if not
more crucial would be developing your
people skills the skills the functional
career skills that we have been talking
about because hard skills are domain
specific power skills or soft skills are
people skills and they are more nuanced
and in this age of collaboration in this
age of high hybrid work of innovative
approach approaches the intangible soft
skills can drive successful work
environments so they consist what are
soft skills basically they consist of
your personal character characteristics
and your personal traits and soft skills
can be uh said to have a sum of your
mindsets and your behaviors so for
instance if you are a lifelong learner
or if you are highly resilient or you
are adaptable it actually speaks of your
mindset similarly if you have characters
of you know characteristics of being a
critical thinker of being curious of
being an active listener of solving a
problem creatively they speak of your
behaviors and hence soft skills are an
amalgam of the correct mindset and the
correct Behavior years and if you have
this if you can develop this then you
will immediately be noticed at your
workplace you will be noticed by the
people who are interviewing you who are
employing you and of course later on
when you start working at your uh
workplace so this is uh this is what
soft skills is about and how can you
differentiate between hard skills and
soft skills like uh let us take an
example so if you are very confident
about handling a particular software
that is your hard skill however if you
can analyze different softwares and
figure out what a company should use it
requires critical thinking and that is a
soft skill
and so as I said it can be assumed that
your qualifications and your experience
can get you an interview it can get you
a job but to sustain scale and enhance
that job and get promoted maybe into a
leadership role you need these power
skills or soft skills so this is the
importance of soft skills in our career
growth now let us look at some of these
important soft skills at uh you know
that are highly valued and
you can see that of course these are the
top 15 skills of 2025 and you can see
that most of them are functional scales
apart from technological skills most of
them are functional skills and that is
why we are stressing on the importance
of developing them so
now let us look at some of these
importance of skills that would be
highly valued in the near future in 2023
and how you can develop them at work so
the first one is creativity now if this
is your ability to generate new and
original ideas
inventiveness and Innovation are
Hallmarks of creativity so your ability
to solve complex problems and
communicate in an insightful manner
displays your creativity now this skill
is important because the world is
continuously getting automated and
however creativity cannot be replicated
by AI by artificial intelligence and
that is why this skill will always be in
demand so let me give you some
actionable tips for developing
creativity what you can do is you can
try new things at the workplace go out
of your comfort zone and you can think
creatively perhaps how to cut costs at
the organization where you are working
you can also think creatively and talk
about yes talk Beyond think beyond your
limits you can think creatively and talk
about yourself you can talk about your
organization you can talk about your
organization's product or services in a
very creative manner maybe on social
media platforms that again displays your
creativity so this is the first one and
the next is collaboration
collaboration is how to get people to
work together more efficiently so
generally a common incentive drives
people to collaborate and if you can
understand that common incentive and the
end results it will bring to you or your
team or your organization you have
mastered this skill so understand why
collaboration is important and the
process of collaboration will enhance
team spirit and it will lead to more
Innovative problem solving again
actionable tips to develop the skill if
you are a team leader perhaps be aware
of certain characteristics or be aware
of the talents of each uh each member of
your team and what they can offer so
that will help of course respect
diversity respect uh uh you know people
are working in your workplace in from
different to different backgrounds
respect all that and develop an
empathetic attitude and the third one is
learn to delegate tasks do not keep
everything to yourself the more you
delegate the more collaboration you will
find happening at your workplace so this
is the second one and now we come to the
art of persuasion now persuasion is
often mistaken for manipulation so uh
you know persuasion is not about
manipulating people it is to advance
everyone's standpoint not just yours so
um it is getting your point across
effectively and it is very useful for
people in the sales and marketing fields
and another thing is an actionable tip
how you can how you can cultivate this
soft scale of persuasion is when you are
looking for a promotion when you are
looking to secure a new job uh when you
are looking for a plum assignment that
you want to do for a for a role that you
want to have then you can use this this
technique this tactics of persuasion by
putting yourself in the spotlight and uh
and and you know uh and making the other
person maybe your boss or your manager
or whoever it is who's interviewing you
making them aware why you are the best
candidate for this job why you are the
best fit for this role so that is how
you can use the art of persuasion next
is critical thinking or very important
skill critical thinking involves
defining the problem asking questions
about it evaluating the evidence and
then considering potential Solutions so
it is an in invaluable skill because it
will help you in your career to make
better decisions actionable actionable
tip for critical thinking trying to be
objective and free from biases and
judgments so when you look at any
situation try to be objective about it
for instance every day we are you know
we are subjected to a lot of information
overload we are bombarded with so much
of information now uh it is very
important to remember to use your
discretion for anything that the media
is feeding you use your discretion and
remain in remain objective about it
though this habit will lead to a lot of
critical thinking the next is
adaptability
now as we know the world is constantly
changing and people are working together
in different time zones different
geographies different cultures different
races people from different backgrounds
all are working together at the
workplace so you need to be adaptable
also maybe a workplace situation or
challenge uh in uh in in a U.S city
would be very different from a workplace
challenge in in an Asian City so you
need to understand the challenges you
need to respond to change and uh you
need to be resilient and you need to be
adaptable if you are like if you are
adaptable you will get more
opportunities and you should understand
that there is not a one-size-fits all
solutions also yesterday's problems will
not or two days yesterday's Solutions
will not form today's problems so try to
evolve all the time try to be flexible
and try to be adaptable now actionable
tip for that since the world is
increasingly becoming volatile and
complex you need to be a continuous
learner a conscious learner remain
flexible in your attitude and aim to
invest in yourself and constantly keep
on Reinventing yourself the next is time
management again a very important skill
here
prioritization is the name of the game
it is important to write down your short
term and your long-term goals both
personal and and professional and work
according to that plan you should also
pers you should also uh you know try to
find a balance between your personal
goals and your professional goals
actionable tips there are so many make
to-do lists have time blocking charts or
make use of some excellent apps like
Pomodoro or follow Stephen scoby's four
quadrant mattress Matrix this is my
favorite the four quadrant Matrix of do
delete delay and delegate so these are
based on your task whether they are
Urgent or important so based on the
urgency and importance you can either do
delegate delay or delete your task so
that is
very important this is a very important
way in which you can manage your time
well and another tip which is also very
important is learn to appreciate other
people's timelines learn to appreciate
other people's deadlines not just your
own so this is about time management
next we have leadership now it's a
misconception that you can display
leadership skills only when you are you
know in a team situation when you are a
manager when you are a CEO or when you
know in the cxo levels leadership is
actually about solving problems and
conflicts and it is about inspiring
people so you need competence you need
assertiveness and you need emotional
intelligence it's that is very important
because you need to manage your emotions
as well as uh the other people's
emotions you should have a very good
understanding of that
and the actionable tip is help people to
move towards common goals and get them
to work together efficiently and the
most important tip again is make your
actions speak louder than words let that
influence and motivate people at any
stage of your career you will have this
leadership quality if you can do that
and while we were talking about
leadership how can emotional
intelligence be behind so it is a highly
sought after skill and you need this in
all aspects of life so humans are not
always rational you know they often uh
they often uh react with their emotions
now at the workplace emotional quotient
or emotional intelligence will help you
to avoid uh will help you to avoid
overreacting to situations it will help
you to avoid overreacting to people and
it will help you to avoid bringing your
emotional baggage into the workplace for
instance if you lose your fool with your
boss or your even with your co-workers
you might have to pay a heavy price for
that so a high degree of emotional
quotient will make you more confident
and actionable tip for developing
emotional intelligences always be
mindful of your behavior at the
workplace
next we come to the next uh very
important skill of decisiveness now here
just avoid having endless debates and
thoughts and pointless discussions over
a topic or situation because nobody
likes a person who is inflicted with
analysis paralysis you know we have
heard of analysis paralysis and that is
keep on thinking and keep on analyzing a
situation until and you know you find no
solution to it so nobody likes that
learn to take informed decisions because
this quality of making calculated
decisions faster than other people is
will be useful when you are working
under pressure so this ability will also
set you apart from other people and it
will uh it will make people sit up and
notice you because you are a decisive
person now and actionable tip for this
take responsibility and ownership for
your decisions once you have made them
stick by it
last but not the least is networking and
how can we negate the importance of
interpersonal skills when we talk of
effective networking so in this
connection it is important to understand
one concept if you provide value to
someone they are more likely to return
the favor that is an important principle
of making new connections be it in
person be it on your professional
platforms on LinkedIn or wherever it is
that if you help more people to get what
they want you will inevitably get what
you want and an actionable tip for
developing and cultivating your
networking skills is networking is
remember it's a two-way game do not just
think of your benefit but also think of
ways you can provide value to others so
these were some of the soft skills just
10 of the soft skills at work and they
will be very very useful if you can
start developing and cultivating them
from now onwards so now that we are
ending 2022 embarking on our new uh year
of 23 think of how you can develop all
these soft skills and you can always
have a great great um
career ahead and think of the mindset
you increase you have to inculcate think
of the skill sets you have to inculcate
and go forward make your goals for 2023.
thank you so much
all right
and we'd like to go into the questions
and answers I'm going to share with you
before that these links that are on the
screen here uh including students email
LinkedIn address
link tree and the link to her book
yes that's a QR code which can be
scanned and
that is LinkedIn yes although and I'm
also going to put the URL into the chat
that you can
scan the
QR code
okay those are in and we'll move on to
um
our q a period
we have a number of questions that have
come in so far
um
Joseph asks
as in a high school graduate who's 36
years old does this all apply to him
yes does it apply to him of course very
much so so he's a high school graduate
is he is he has he started working
somewhere I are yeah I'm assumed
is 36 years old so he's
sure he's making a living
um okay yes so he is leaving so 36 I
would say he is reaching uh the
mid-career level and uh you know as I
said one needs to be a continuous
learner I have emphasized on that
repeatedly so when you are working in
the beginning of your career when you're
working you started working that is the
time for Learning and observing however
when you have been in your career for a
few years then it is time to upskill and
then it is time to go to the next level
and this is the right time when you are
36 trying to see what try to take into
account take stock of your career till
now you must have set some goals in the
beginning of your career have you
reached those goals are you satisfied
with where you are at present do you
need to change do you need to have
another a different industry that you
want to go to are you satisfied with
where you are are you getting your
promotions on time do you find your work
challenging or not so you you need to
answer all these questions and then you
see whether or not you are at the right
place if not always try to see which
skills you are lacking always try to see
whether you need to reskill and upskill
or uh you know take a sabbatical
whatever it is because at the mid-career
level it is all about scaling up and at
this stage there is very little there is
a lot of competition and there is uh you
know uh only a few people can go to the
next level that is to the leadership
level and that is why it is important to
be well armed with uh whatever
challenges that are going to be coming
up in the near future well armed with
the right kind of skills and the right
kind of mindset so that is what I have
been emphasizing on and definitely all
these skills are are going to help you
okay thank you
um
so related to that Fatima asks if you
can succeed in life without going to
University
there are so many that's such an
interesting question uh Padma and you
don't really need to go to the
university because you know there is a
this mindset that education is
everything if you are well educated you
will be uh you know successful in life
no not so uh you could be passionate
about so many other things as I said
when you are a student when you are in
high school you know that there are so
many things that interest you find out
about your passion and see if it can
lead to somewhere maybe you can become
an entrepreneur we have talked about
um uh you know this person called uh
Harlan Sanders who is the founder of KFC
so he was a school dropout he was not
educated but he had the resilience of
spirit those are the things that are
important if you are motivated enough if
you believe in what you are doing if you
are passionate about a certain subject a
topic or a certain activity just go
ahead with learning that deep dive into
it do not go into extensive things
because University and you know are our
kind of educational system teaches so
many different things which might or
might not be valuable but if you have
found your core interest just Deep dive
into it learn everything about it become
an expert and then the sky is the limit
you will always be in demand so this is
what I feel University education is
specifically not important if you want
to have Career Success not really
yeah there's a big debate in the United
States about the value of University
education and people are pointing out
that depending on what you've studied in
University you may end up with a lot of
uh student loan debt and less earning
potential than someone who went into a
technical trade directly from high
schools though it all depends on where
you're going and what your your ultimate
plan is there are so many vocational
courses that they can do so that you
know it doesn't take more than six
months or one year you are trained in
that and then you can go forward yeah
uh rockvan asks how to UPS upgrade to
the kind of multiple multi-level skill
set like you have which is
he says in our routine work we don't get
much time for learning so what advice do
you give to somebody who needs to carve
out
that time to learn and grow
time of course uh I think we all have
the time we are all busy people but if
you have the interest as I said time
management or prioritization you are
busy at your work but when you come back
or maybe in the morning come out
sometime for your you know for any
activity that you want to learn for any
skill that you want to upgrade you know
for any skill that you want to learn
again uh you know enhance your prospects
enhance your talents so time management
is very important and as I said you can
make a to-do list always have a to-do
list or uh you know a time block
we call it a Time block chart or a
calendar so anything that you want to
learn you can fit in half an hour or one
hour into your day and learn that so uh
you know being busy everyone has the
same 24 hours some people achieve so
much more some people and keep on
talking about lack of time so
so I'm going to put into the Q a by the
way in response to a similar question
you did a webinar with us uh January of
this year about time management and I'm
going to link to that yes
and uh
in the meantime
um
best rumor uh says we say Bloom where
you are planted how does that hold for a
negative environment
um where you don't feel like you have
the soil to to grow
to bloom
okay so uh if it is a
named in the sense that uh if she is
talking about uh people who are not a
very you know you're not uh not very
conducive to work with or maybe uh the
manager or the seniors are not very uh
helpful so if she is talking about that
kind of a toxic environment the first
thing you should do is take action about
it why not if you feel that some person
is hampering your growth or not letting
you grow the way you want to in an
organization why not have a one-to-one
with that person straight away now if
that is not possible and if you have
done it and if you have failed it has
had no effect then you need to take
certain other measures and
um you can think of uh you know if you
cannot just survive in that kind of an
environment uh why not uh think of
changing you know not immediately but
why not thinking of changing your job
also that I would suggest because uh
your growth is very important your
personal development is also very
important and if you are not allowed to
grow like this in your place of work
then you need to think about it
seriously because you cannot stagnate in
that place where you are put down all
the time you need to think about it
maybe take some time off uh do not leave
your job immediately take some time off
in the mornings in the evenings and try
to work on your own self and then when
you have acquired certain skills you may
think of switching your job to a better
environment
that makes sense uh vinay asks sometimes
we have fulfillment and work aligned to
our organizational goal all of that is
wonderful but our compensation
is less compared to the industry
um and less than what we feel we need
how do you make a decision about that
situation what are the options you can
have
yeah so if you feel that your
remuneration is not up to the mark you
feel that you deserve more than first of
all you have to self-introspect why am I
getting less than the industry standard
so you ask yourself that
uh maybe I am just doing my routine job
maybe I am just doing what the job
description has asked me to do and I'm
not going beyond that role at all am I
providing value more value to my
organization am I taking on more
initiatives am I doing certain things
which I have not been asked to do so am
I doing all these things and making
myself noticeable to the uh to the
managers or to the decision makers ask
yourself that and if you feel that yes
you are contributing a lot then you
should again have a talk with the people
and you should say that this is what I
have did this is what my skill sets are
this is what my role is and I'm doing so
much more as well I am providing value
to my organization give them concrete
figures and then ask for a raise and uh
you know or whatever it is that you are
looking for ask for that and you will
surely get it so first of all you have
to make an effort to make them realize
that you are a valuable asset to the
organization only then will they give
you that kind of a raise that you are
looking for
thank you
um
so we have several questions from people
who are looking to switch
from one domain to another
uh geody for example says uh
gonna get a job if I have a bcom degree
in good knowledge of java
Rakesh is in a construction company I.T
Department
and wants to move formally into the I.T
sector
concurs a network architect
feels his job has become stagnant and
repetitive and and
he's worried about ageism at mid-career
he's
this is 35 years old with 12 years of
experience but he's wondering if he's
getting too old to do a job switch how
what do you advise to people in the
situation where they want to make that
25 35 is not at all to do a job switch
not at all you're young enough and as I
said you are approaching your mid-career
level this is the time this is the
deciding time you know whether you want
to stagnate in your job or you want to
grow so if you want to grow maybe look
at your skill sets look at your skill
sets if you want you can go for a
sabbatical and upskill look for that
that option is always there and uh in
your job or whatever a job that you're
doing uh have you displayed any
leadership skills for example or any
other soft skills so these kind of
skills you know adaptability leadership
skills Communications these are all
transferable skills that means they can
be transferred from one industry to
another so uh these are cross-functional
skills
all these skills can be helpful in any
industry that you go to so do not think
that you can be uh you will uh be
redundant in some other place because
you have certain skills which you can
highlight so carry those skills from
this job to your next job whichever one
you want to do and highlight when you
are going for interviews highlight what
achievements what skills you have which
can be transferred to the next job so
yes it is never too late to switch jobs
not at all
okay and that kind of relates to a
question from chaitali who asks about
having completed a professional
certificate in blockchain how does he
deal with companies who want
professional experience how does he
emphasize his qualifications
um
so that they look past
hiring him as a fresh
okay so she doesn't have the requisite
qualifications for that perhaps uh has
the qualifications through a
professional certificate
um but not professional experience
experience yes so this also happens then
what you can go uh what you can do is if
you have the skills but not the
experience you can join a not-for-profit
organization if that is possible join a
not-for-profit organization work there
work on improving your skills over there
and using and learning uh your skills
over there and of course you will not be
paid maybe you can do something on the
weekend and you know contribute in that
place in that not for organization uh
not for profit organization and brush up
your skills over there that way you will
gain the experience so that when you are
ready to come back to this job you will
be well armed with experience as well
which you can use in the existing job
we have a couple of questions about
career breaks Nancy asked how do you
stay motivated during an extended career
break and
um
Puja asks how do you handle a career
break just in general when you're trying
to re-enter the workforce
yeah so uh career breaks of course are
very common these days and it's not even
a big issue now uh there are so many
reasons that can you know lead you to
have a career break uh for instance uh
you are a woman so maybe uh you are
raising a family or for any other reason
I'm not even talking about that so when
you want to re-enter the workforce you
find that whatever you had been doing
because technology is advancing at a
very rapid space uh rapid pace so
whatever skills that you are using at
that time your technical skills that you
feel are now outdated suppose you join
after four or five years or you're
thinking of joining after four or five
years so the first thing when you are
taking a career break is time find time
to keep up with the changing skills
always important to upskill always
important to see what your industry
demands because because of the changing
scenarios what are the skills that are
most in demand in your industry and with
that in mind keep on learning new skills
and do not be guilty I mean as you're
saying how to handle it do not be guilty
about taking a career break because you
must have taken it for a very valid
reason so stick with your decision but
always keep your networking skills alive
because when you were working there were
so many people you were in contact with
and always keep those connections alive
because you know people buy from people
so Word of Mouth recommendations will
also help and if you are in touch with
those people they can always pitch in uh
you know they can always put in a good
word for you when you think of rejoining
so these are certain things which you
can do and then when you are rejoining
you go for your your interviews be
confident about yourself because now you
are armed with all those skills that
your role demands so these are some of
the ways in which you can stay positive
about about a career break and still go
back and rejoin at the same level or
even better than that
thank you
um answer ask question what do you do
when you get confused about choosing a
career path how do you get clarity on
that
yes so choosing a career path it's very
important to find out your purpose your
why is very important there is a very
nice book find your why uh is it find
your why or start with Why by Simon
sinek so then that says that what is
your purpose in life the same concept is
shared in the book called ikigai why do
you want to do a certain thing what is
the root cause is it you want a job
because of the money is it because you
want to sustain a family is it because
because of you know faster promotions so
find out exactly what your aim is and
then go and choose your career path so
your purpose in in finding your
professional life your purpose in your
uh personal life is very important
because you need to have a work life
balance and your why then becomes very
important in choosing your career path
and
and getting close to the end of the
available time so I just want to ask
uh one more question I think which has
to do with
um
how do you put your best foot forward
how do you give a good we have a
question from Abdul who says
um it's a bachelor of engineering and
ECE how does he
just graduating and how do you give a
good effective self-introduction
to let people know what you're about and
why they should for example hire you
okay so uh this person has no experience
he is still to enter the work Arena I
suppose
yes so uh then uh when you are uh going
for an interview uh which is what I
assume uh you would be doing soon
you you will have to of course the first
question might be tell me something more
tell me something about yourself so do
not introduce yourself in the regular
way my name I mean I have my college my
education my qualifications because all
that is already there in your resume so
what you have to talk about is why you
have been chosen why you have been
called for this interview why you have
been thought capable enough that you are
sitting in this interview so talk about
your achievements even as a student you
have so many achievements which you can
highlight talk about where all you have
in turn you know your internships are
important is there anything that you
have achieved in those internships any
awards any accolades any skills that you
can highlight also talk about the so
many uh volunteering activities that you
might have gone through you might have
undertaken so all these things will
bring out your skills in a very very
subtle manner so you don't have to talk
about your skill I have leadership
skills or I have uh you know I'm a team
player the way you introduce yourself
talking about your achievements your
volunteers volunteering activities your
internships and uh you know all these
things that you have achieved in your
students life that itself will bring out
whether or not you are the right person
for the job or not so this is the way
you must introduce yourself be creative
about it tell a story about yourself but
be very very subtle about highlighting
certain traits that you have
highlighting certain qualities that you
have so it might seem like a story but
you are putting in your qualities and
skills that the other person will
appreciate so this is one way of
introducing
thank you okay and I apologize to
everyone we had
over 4 000 and almost 5 000 people who
registered for today's webinar
and so with about a thousand people
showing up
um we had far more questions than we
could get to so I apologize if we
haven't gotten to your question
um but I'm going to
um go ahead and
get to the conclusions of the webinar
oops sorry
doing the wrong thing here
this is the button I meant to push
so we've just concluded questions and
answers
I'm going to go back real quick sorry
for the flashing here
and run the poll that I was not able to
run before
um this gives us a kind of a feel for
who's in the audience
come on
all right
oh my gosh
oh good lord
he's doing it again
okay
some issues there oh I am
back
hello again
and I'm not able to share my screen
without causing a failure of the system
so I'm just going to go ahead and run
pull without slides
for some reason when I share my screen
the
system freezes up on me so I'm not going
to do that
we're just going to go ahead and go to
the conclusion of the program I am going
to ask
I can one polling question
nope not allowed
so uh I have to say thank you to
everybody
um and
we're going to um
say thank you to SEMA for spending so
much time with us in engineering so
generously of her knowledge
really appreciate that
and um
we thank you all for being here we
advise you to
follow us on Twitter and
Facebook at simply learn
and you can follow us on LinkedIn
simply learn is the name and then we
look forward to seeing you at future
webinars we'll be on Zoom the next time
you see us
instead of WebEx and hopefully that
means we won't have these types of
technical difficulties so again thank
you everyone for being here and thank
you SEMA thank you so much Stuart thank
you all the participants would love to
connect with everyone thank you okay
take care and have a great rest of your
day or evening